[Music]
6 11 here it is a tuesday morning and it
is time now for our in your business
segment and peter guzman is joining us
from the latin chamber of commerce
we've been talking about business peter
all morning long because of the new
restrictions that are in place
announced by governor sysolak over the
weekend so these 20
these new restrictions this has a big
effect on your restaurants all sorts of
different businesses around town
what are you hearing from the latin
businesses here in southern nevada
about the effect of these new
restrictions
yeah you know uh ironically uh the
response so far has been hey
uh we're glad we're at least being able
to stay open and not completely
uh closed down that's where the real
fear was was a complete closure and so
uh you know they're they're i wouldn't
say excited but
the opportunity to stay open and and
still produce
is uh it keeps them hopeful you know i
think it was the nevada restaurant
association that was saying that maybe
30 percent of the restaurants in town
uh could close by december i acknow we
acknowledge that it's not just
restaurants that are being affected by
these new restrictions here but
how worried are the business leaders
you're talking to
about their survival business-wise
yeah i mean listen we're going through a
pandemic everybody's worried
running a business is uh is a tough
profit margin even before covet so
imagine now it's even more challenging
and with all these restrictions yeah it
becomes challenging but
you're seeing some of these restaurants
pivot uh which is what entrepreneurs do
pivot to outdoor dining uh curbside
more of all of that stuff i think
outdoor dining is gonna become a big
deal
um and part of the business plan and so
again uh
you know not an exciting time but
certainly hopeful that uh they're able
to at least stay open and produce a
little bit of
revenue but it's definitely a challenge
and there's some nervousness
the local latin community the the
hispanic community has been hit is
particularly hard by the coronavirus the
number of cases
and that and those parts of the valley
have are higher than all
other parts adding this as another layer
here
it seems like this is a a pretty
difficult mixture to try and navigate
when you talk to folks in the community
about that what are they telling you
about
their abilities moving forward
well listen you know the the hispanic
culture lends itself to
to uh to be vulnerable on a situation
like this because
families tend to live in bigger groups
together uh you know grandma and grandpa
uh living at home and then you have
living at home so youngsters can bring
that home as you know
uh last month we the latin chamber gave
out over 25
000 reusable masks in trying to
curve that the terrible pandemic that
we're going through
but at the end of the day um we're all
going through it together
there are some things that we can do uh
i believe to
to help uh minimize and that is wearing
the mask and that's why we're
encouraging everybody to
you know wear the mask do their part and
and get tested if you have a symptom
and and let's keep vegas open as much as
we can we're
it seems like we're getting close to a
vaccine so keeping us
open keeps us hopeful when it comes to
final question here to
assistants though a lot of this depends
on the federal government obviously but
what discussions have you had with
lawmakers whether it's clark county
legislators or the governor's office
about some sort of financial assistance
either for businesses to stay open or
maybe just people trying to stay in
their homes
well truly i i do believe that we as
a state and local municipalities have
done an amazing job the county
it just announced another round of help
for small businesses
we've been involved with the tri
chambers uh in giving out grant dollars
the state the the treasury uh
has been working really hard and getting
an additional 20 million dollars
uh in funds for small business we know
that small business is the engine that
runs
uh not only our communities but our
country and so everything we can do to
get dollars in their hands and keep them
open
gives us a fighting chance a long way to
go
hopefully not too much longer but uh the
the hope is there hopefully the money
and the assistance will be as well peter
thank you for joining us again this
morning we know there's a big challenge
ahead for our local businesses we
appreciate it peter good to see you
always a pleasure being with you and
thank you for highlighting things like
this of course